ابن
[موسيقى]
ابن ما زالت الحرب هنا انتهت ولم تنتهي
عاد العم محمد واولاده الى ديارهم لكن
ارضهم لم تعد اليهم فم خفات الحرب باقيه
فيها احنا مرج ولحد الان موجوده ما انزرعت
متروك هاي تقريبا من 2016 ولحد
الان مساحه تقريبا والله اذا اقول لك بال
50 الى 100 دونم موجوده لحد الان هاي
كانكم منطقتنا هنا بس كزراعة
على واقع صعب في
[موسيقى]
الانبار كنا نتحضر لمقابله احد المسؤولين
المحليين هنا للحصول على معلومات بشان
حقول الالغام في البصره فوردت معلومات
تفيد بانفجار قنبله من مخلفات الحروب في
طفلتين بمنطقه البرجسيه في قضاء الزبير
قبل قليل نحن الان في الطريق الى
هناك
قنبله من مخلفات حرب عام 91 كما يعتقد
اهالي القريه انفجرت في نرجس ونوره توفيت
نرجس على الفور وبقيت اختها تصارع الموت
في
[موسيقى]
المستشفى يا
ابويا التاسعه مساء ينتظر ذو الطفلتين
استلام جثمان
نرجس يا ح
يا خبر حزين اخر للعائله الطفله نوره
توفيت ايضا يا
اخوي يا حزم يا
اخوي لقيت بلوكه من شنب نيشان احمر خط
احمر من شنون جماعتهم يقولوا لهم اذا تجون
تلقون خط احمر على ها يعني احنا تصور هييك
يعني من لقوها هذن شنوها بخط احمر ليش ما
فجروها نرجس ونوره طفلتان قتلتهما الان
حرب وقعت قبل اكثر من 30 عاما حاله ليست
سوى تعبير عن واقع ماساوي في البصره الشا
هذا ها الخطوط الحمراء طبعا تعبر عن مواقع
التلوث الموجود راح تشوفون انه حجم التلوث
الكبير في محافظه البصره خصوصا في قضاء شط
العرب وفي قضاء الفاو وفي مناطق الزبط
وايضا هناك تلوث كبير موجود في في جنوب
محافظه المثنى بين الحدود بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
والعراق تعمل الفرق الدوليه المختصه
بالتعاون مع الحكومه على ازاله الالغام
حتى الان في مناطق مختلفه من الانبار رغم
مرور اكثر من خمس سنوات على نهايه الحرب
هنا حيث تشكل الطبيعه الوعره والمساحات
الشاسعه ابرز المعوقات امام الوقت وسرعه
[موسيقى]
الانجاز تمت معضله اخرى تواجهها هذه الفرق
هي طبيعه الالغام والقنابل غير المنفل
التي صنعت محليا وبطرق معقده
في محافظه الانبار هي كلها
مبتكره فهذه العبوات المبتكره
هي اول شيء تكون ايجادها
صعب
عمليه التفجير مالتها يكون مختلف عن
النظامي عن العبوات النظاميه او الالغام
النظاميه لان هي بطبيعه الحال ما
لها جسم معين او او شكل معين
خمس سنوات تفصل العراقيين عن موعد حددته
السلطات هنا لرفع شعار عراق خال من
الالغام نظرا لادخال معدات حديثه تعمل على
رفع المخلفات ولكن تبقى هناك معوقات عده
قد تقف امام ذلك العائق الاكبر اللي
يواجهنا هو العائق المادي وانا اقوله بكل
صراحه بانه برنامج شون الالغام نحن نعمل
الان على الازاله بالمتر وعليك ان تتخيل
حضرتك يجب التاكد من كل متر للاراضي
الملوثه في في مفاهيم الالغام اذا كان
لديك 10 ي متر مربع واكتشفت عبوه ناسفه او
مخلف حربي او لغم تعتبر هذه الارض كلها
ملوثه وعليك ان تمسحها بدقه قبل ان تعطي
شهاده اطلاق او ما يسمى بكلير سيرتيفيكيت
ما زالت البصره تحتفظ بالحصه الاكبر من
الالغام والص
واجسام اخرى غير منفل جراء الحروب
المتعاقبه التي شهدتها المدينه قد يكون
هذا الحي الصوره الاكثر وضوحا لقصه العراق
مع الالغام يطلق عليه قريه البتران اي
مبتوري الاطراف اغلبيه من عاصروا سنوات
الحرب تعرضوا لحوادث اثر انفجار لغم او
صاروخ غير منفل اثناء محاولتهم الحصول على
المعادن في تلك
[موسيقى]
الاجسام انا قاعد اطلع عل معيشتي على ه
صدام حسين نطلع وهسه قاعد نطلع لا عندي
راتب ال جالي معيشه ما عندي اجيب لي ه
الصفر كيلو كيلو وانا اعيش بها جهالي لحد
الان
نطلع بس اليوم ما طلعت انا
قاعد اكثر من ربع الاراضي الزراعيه في
البلاد تحضر الزراعه فيها بسبب الالغام
حتى الان وكذلك البنى التحتيه ناهيك عن
الطرق التي ما زالت مقطو
وحتى مجرى انهار فرعيه احصائيات ساهمت
بشكل رئيسي في تعطيل الاستثمار في مناطق
مختلفه بل وضربت حياه الناس احيانا فالعدو
الخفي دخل ولم يخرج منذ اكثر من 40 عاما
قتل واعاقه من وقف امامه بقصد او من دون
قصد سامر يوسف الجزيره
[موسيقى]
بغداد m